welcome back to new rockstars it's me mt
and the book of boba fett finale finally
silenced the millions of voices that
cried out in terra when grogu got ripped
away from his father's embrace to go to
space magic sunday school by finally
having the mandalorian reunite with
grogu as they light speed cruise out of
view in a naboo nunu with room for two
built by a nice lady with a robot crew
but while everything's great for grogu
what about luke skywalker huh like what
comes next for luke after his would-be
student of his new jedi order ditched
him for his overprotective power ranger
of a papa could grogu's rejection of the
jedi path in the book of boba fett
finale have been the first domino that
tipped towards the eventual downfall of
luke skywalker's actual future first
student of the jedi order ben solo
dooming millions of people in the galaxy
to die from his allegiance with snoke's
first order let's meditate on that
together my beautiful nerd baby padawans
because i truly do believe that luke
skywalker's inclusion in the book of
boba fett is lucasfilm's way of helping
audiences understand luke skywalker's
actions in the last jedi so to quickly
recap gregor's choice at the end of the
book of boba fett 6 was of course
between foregoing all past personal
attachments and thus receiving the gift
of yoda's lightsaber and continued
training in the ways of the force or
giving into those past attachments by
accepting his cool new shirt that his
daddy made in however with grogu
choosing his love for his father mando
over a life of selfless boringness with
luke he failed luke's test on whether or
not rogue was fit to be a jedi in the
first place because as we know all too
well from the jedi order in the prequel
trilogy they were very much fearful of
things like passion and attachment
because in their opinion they believe
that these connections were a very
slippery slope that could easily lead
even the most devout jedi to the dark
side now this all being said we also
know that luke skywalker would not go on
to bring his 10 year old nephew ben solo
as his new jedi order's first student
until six years after goku's decision to
go on a ride in his dad's new car
instead meaning that ben solo was about
four years old during the time of this
episode of the mandalorian and during
all that time and even a bit before luke
skywalker was making it his personal
mission to rediscover the complete lost
history of the jedi order by traveling
around the galaxy playing uncharted in
tomb raider across the various hidden
jedi temples with laura santeka from the
force awakens this is because luke heard
that lor santeka was the super dope
space explorer who grew up during the
tail end of the clone wars and had
already spent decades looking for jedi
temples and just being obsessed with the
jedi culture as much as luke was and
according to the rise of skywalker
visual dictionary the reason why luke
took these six years to learn more about
the jedi is because he just didn't feel
ready to be a good enough jedi master to
a new generation of jedi not without
first learning of the deep history of
the jedi versus struggle that caused his
father anakin to be led astray and
annihilate trillions of people in the
first place now if you grew up
collecting pokemon or magic the
gathering cards and wants something to
scratch that competitive collecting itch
raid shadow legends has over 600 champs
waving at you ready to collect and do
battle use the links below to download
raid to your mobile phone or pc one of
the most fun parts of the game is
opening up shards to get new champions
let's open up some sacred shards oh
sanguina okay no big deal miscreated
monster very cool he's a big
frankenstein guy that's a great support
champion oh dang a legendary champion
saito he's a cool samurai looking hard
hitter that's going to be a big help to
my account raid's got a ton happening
this month with a fresh rotation of the
brutal hydra boss and a ton of events
and tournaments every single day
including some special valentine's day
events where you can get your hands on a
brand new legendary champion this is the
best time to get started in raid and if
you click my link in the description or
scan the qr code here on the screen
you'll get cool bonuses we're talking a
free epic champion aina 200 000 silver
one energy refill one xp boost and one
ancient shard so you can summon awesome
champions as soon as you get in game and
all this treasure will be waiting for
you here luke knew all too well that
those who do not learn from the past are
doomed to repeat it and this is where
grogu's choice comes most into play
because unfortunately despite luke's
desire to learn from the past luke had
no idea that his obsession over the jedi
and how they did things in the past was
fueled primarily by his own biggest flaw
his immensely deep fear of the dark side
undoubtedly rooted in what he saw the
dark side do to his father darth vader i
believe that luke's fear of the dark
side coupled with his blind idolization
of the jedi order caused him to miss the
jedi order's biggest flaw one that we
the audience saw all too clearly with
anakin's dark decline the removal of
choice because one of the biggest
contributing factors to the creation of
darth vader in the first place was the
very stringent commands of the jedi
religion the jedi fear that passionate
emotions like love could lead people to
attachment that could then lead a
powerful jedi weapon towards tempting
dark side feelings of suffering and hate
so they swore off all feelings of
passion altogether which sounded like
great advice to them until you know the
strongest force user of all time the
dichlorians fell in love with natalie
portman and then started having visions
of her dying and that's when yoda's just
let a go man type of approach just
didn't cut it out for anakin leading him
to pursue dark side methods of saving
the woman he loved because instead of
having a balanced view of the force like
qui-gon did and accepting that anakin
skywalker was a human being with
emotions that needed help navigating
those emotions the jedi creed merely
just told him to just let padme go let's
let her die like don't even worry about
it and because luke skywalker was just
this huge jedi simp for everything about
jedi history and loved everything about
the jedi council from a distance he just
blindly mirrored their flawed ideology
with grogu who was a literal baby so
yeah unfortunately luke likely learned
the wrong lesson from groku's choice to
be with the mandalorian and now fears
the temptation of attachments even more
especially when his next first student
is going to be his own nephew who his
sister leia told luke had a very
concerning darkness already growing
inside of him because to luke much like
the jedi religion of old he foolishly
believes that when given the choice to
forgo attachments the most powerful
force sensitives in training will likely
not be able to resist those attachments
which is why i am of the strong belief
that when older luke has a vision of
ben's dark future 13 years into ben's
training luke's fear of the dark side
and its potential to tempt ben into
becoming a monster with attachments like
his father causes luke to ignite his
lightsaber over a sleeping ben solo
because he feels like he needs to take
ben's choice into his own hands to
prevent another darth vader from
terrorizing the galaxy again cause like
anakin and grogu before ben the kids are
simply much too weak to resist dark side
passion so for a split second luke
debated robbing ben solo of his own
choice but unfortunately a split second
was all it took for ben to see his uncle
about to choose his devotion to religion
over the literal life of his
blood-related nephew thus causing ben to
destroy the very academy that luke spent
all that time trying to build and
becoming kylo ren the very thing that
luke tried to avoid because at the end
of the day star wars has always been
about balance all about bringing balance
to the force and finding balance within
yourself much like light cannot exist
without darkness a life without passions
isn't much of a life at all however
because of luke's obsession with the
foolish emotional suppression of the
jedi order of the past grogu's rejection
of the jedi way likely served as a
cautionary tale to luke to cling tighter
to the emotionally unbalanced teachings
of the jedi rather than as an
opportunity for grogu to learn balance
and experience the best of both worlds
because why couldn't grogu just be a
jedi but also see his dad sometimes
what
oh that doesn't make any sense that's
some old school jedi man but that's
just what i think what do you guys think
let us know in the comment section below
my beautiful nerd baby padawans but
anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this video please hit up the
rockstarsmerch.com you can get cool
shirts like this you can follow me at
mastertainment if you want to see me
tweet some really weird but again
thank you guys so much for watching this
video i love you guys so much and i will
see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you